[Music]
how would you describe tonight's
premiere and a few words for us the most
dramatic season here if you had to put a
number on it what percentage of the
premiere would you say is about the
scandal and the fallout after the
scandal versus other stuff ooh
I mean I'd say 20% is about the scandal
because we definitely talked about it
we certainly don't shy away from it how
many hookups will we see in the premiere
oh geez
do we need to count I don't remember I'm
sorry how many people will we see cry in
the premiere I don't think we'll see any
tears in the premiere but there's plenty
of tears on the way okay no tears quite
yet how many people will we see a little
tipsy in the premiere everybody that's
that for Taylor okay who got the wildest
in paradise once you guys are resumed
filming I would say jazz mix you want a
TV ABC I'm up to give you good TV who
cries the most see some sad Christina
which guy causes the most drama with the
girls like who's everybody fighting over
I mean who do you think will ADR the
guys fighting over that is I I think we
all knew that Raven was gonna be there
so like everyone walked in and being
like I want to date Raven all right that
last question who causes the most drama
ran into Mario Erina
[Music]
you